hello and welcome to the program
Israel's prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has announced a series of
measures after seven Israelis were
killed and five wounded in two shootings
the move followed a four-hour meeting of
his security cabinet which took place
late on Saturday
now the homes of Palestinians suspected
of being involved in the attacks are to
be demolished the government will also
make it easier for settlers to own guns
by fast-tracking licenses and it will
strengthen the policy the police and
military with operations plan to arrest
people and collect illegal weapons
the Attorney General up to this moment
and every two hours I was in contact
with her people is not allowing us to
seal any houses in my opinion this is
awful in my opinion it can't be like
that in my opinion it is not only to
hurt me and to hurt the government but
the citizens of Israel
beyond the issue of sealing the houses
there's a further list of steps I've
requested which I hope won't face
obstacles first there's house demolition
to my astonishment there are tens of
houses in East Jerusalem which is still
not demolished and it's still possible
to demolish them I directed the police
in the coming days to demolish those
illegal houses and there's the issue of
weapons I want weapons on the streets I
want the citizens of Israel to be able
to defend themselves
let's go straight to our correspondent
James Bays who is live for us in West
Jerusalem yesterday the Prime Minister
outlined these tough new measures
targeting family members of those
involved in the shootings he also talked
about making guns more available for
Israelis what more can we expect from
the team today
well we know that in addition to the
security cabinet meeting which has made
these decisions specific decisions on
security matters there is the wider
cabinet the full cabinet which is
meeting shortly so that may have some
follow-up work from what has been
decided by the security cabinet I think
one of the problems the security cabinet
faced is that this is not the recent
incidence we've seen and not attacks
carried out by members of any one group
in the past for example Hamas have
carried out an attack and you see the
Israelis carry out a strike on Hamas in
Gaza this is more difficult for them to
respond to because these are soul
attackers we think operating on their
own and that's why I think what we've
seen from the security cabinet are
measures that many in the International
Community will consider Revenge tactics
and Collective punishment for example
demolishing the homes of the suspects
well their family homes where families
live and there's no evidence so so far
that any of those families knew what was
being planned and yet they are going to
be caught up in this Collective
punishment we understand that family
members friends may be arrested as well
we also understand that they're likely
to be stripped of their Jerusalem IDs
meaning that they could no longer live
in East Jerusalem and will be expelled
from the city where those families may
have lived for very many years the other
tactics that you've or the other
measures that have been announced by the
security cabinet well one is to speed up
the issuing of gun licenses that means
more guns on the street already the
Israeli police encouraging Israeli
citizens who have gun licenses to
actually carry their weapons in public
and that again many fear many
International observers fear is just
going to lead to more violence when
you've got people wandering the streets
fully armed and the other aspect of this
which specifically in the statement from
the security cabinet is in response
celebrations Palestinian celebrations
and there were some in response to the
most recent attacks and that is more
settlement that they're going to we
think and maybe the full cabinet will
add to what we've heard from the
security cabinet on this authorize more
building on Palestinian land uh just
stress that of course that under
numerous Security Council resolutions
which are binding international law is
totally illegal goes against the whole
International communities uh peace
process and its plans for a two-state
solution because of course the more land
you build on Palestinian land the less
likely it is to be able to have an
independent Palestinian State indeed
James tomorrow the U.S Secretary of
State Anthony blinken arrives in Israel
could that end up having a de-escalating
effect on the recent tensions
yeah secretary blinking will be making
his way from Washington DC first to
Cairo well we'll be meeting with the
Egyptians who clearly have some uh role
in this and will that the discussions in
Cairo will mainly be linked to what's
going on here uh then he'll be coming to
Jerusalem meeting with prime minister
Netanyahu meeting with other key members
of the most right-wing Israeli
government that we've ever seen and this
is his first meeting here since that
government's coming to office and then
he'll be heading uh at the end of his
visit We Believe on Tuesday to Ramallah
to see uh the Palestinian Authority
leadership
will the current violence change the U.S
position because the U.S position really
is not to get involved it's to watch
what's going on urge restraint but not
to actively involve themselves in any
peacemaking we saw certainly the Trump
Administration was actively involved uh
in uh in what it said was peacemaking
the Palestinian side said that they were
promoting a solution that was very much
an Israeli made uh plan uh that really
uh would not have left any viable
Palestinian State well since Joe Biden
came into office he's not pursued those
Trump plans but he's not really doing
much at all and many other members of
the International Community would like
to see much more International
engagement they'd like to see more
criticism of Israel what's stopping that
is the Biden Administration which really
doesn't want to get dragged into this
conflict it's focusing its energy on
other things particularly the war in
Ukraine will Secretary of State blinking
coming here seeing things for himself
will it change the Biden uh the Biden
Administration position let's see but
I'm somewhat doubtful
for now thank you James Bay is there for
us in West Jerusalem